it's time now for CBS morning's deals
where we share some items that might
help make your day a little bit better
all at exclusive discounts this week's
we're bringing back the best of the best
some of the best deals that we've had to
help you ring in the New Year to start
shopping now scan the QR code on your
screen right now or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert Elizabeth
Warner joins us now so let's kick these
things off what's going on here is this
uh something that will help you relax
yeah talk about the best of the best
these are it calming heat sauna wrap so
I'm going to jump in here okay this is
actually bringing the spa experience
home it's an infrared sauna so that
brings all that heat to our body you can
actually feel the heat in here if you
want it brings the heat to the body but
not to the room around us making it more
comfortable more tolerable so we can get
all those toxins out have our muscles
and our joints recover from exercise New
Year New You right yeah that's why I
know my exercise long weekend of
drinking eating bad might be that check
some stuff out I'll tell you the secret
to athletes is that we get an Asana all
of the time yeah it helps us get this
great recovery so right now this is an
unbelievable deal 150 off so it's 149.99
that's really good for couples where one
couple's always cold the other one's not
oh okay I love that all right so you're
looking now at the better better this is
going to help us not only make our beds
but keep them tidy the sheets actually
go into this so we place it around the
bed like a headband okay you then just
tuck your sheets into this no more
struggling pulling on the mattress
making it difficult so and the sheets
falling everywhere while you're trying
to sleep that's exactly right so it's
nice and comfortable now the kids the
teenagers they have no excuse they're
going to make that nice bed it's really
really amazing 50 off so just twenty
dollars and unbelievable your bed's
gonna look like
yeah
of course what do we got here so this is
Jump smart this is an absolutely
necessary 10 in one tool for your car
and home so I'm going to hand you this
here you open this up and on the bottom
that is where you're going to put these
jumper cables because this actually can
jump start your vehicles your SUV your
car your boat it slides right into there
you no longer need the help of a
stranger dual USB ports great power so
when you're out and about you lose power
at home you're in the car you can charge
all your devices but if you flip it
around it's also a flashlight it's got
strobe lights it's got red lights in
there it has it all you name it all it's
got a compass a thermometer a reflector
everything you need so this is a great
safety tool right now 25 off just
119.99 think about all those people that
were trapped in their cars during the
blizzard that's exactly right all the
storms that we've had this year if you
have little ones you never want to be
without power so it's truly a safety
device but for me with the kids I want
it in the car I don't have to worry must
okay now talk about power when we're out
and about this is the rush charge Comet
this is amazing so no matter what device
you have this takes all of the questions
out of which charger to choose you got
all of them no matter what phone you
have no matter what device you're
charging okay these will work so it's
got the micro USB the lightning and the
type C if you don't get all the cords
don't need all the chords there's no
chords at all plugs directly and and you
can use any up to it gives you 25 hours
25 hours and by the way you can use any
charger at home to charge it because on
the bottom it's got the availability for
no matter what charger you have and it's
so small
it's really light because the ones that
I have are always heavy so it's like I'm
gonna bring it but then my bag's going
to be super heavy that's right right in
your pocket right in your pocket and go
so right now 21 off it is 54.99 don't
leave home without that okay now when
you have a little one at home yeah and
you're chasing that toddler hit me good
all right yeah here you go now you just
have that around it's a hook and loop
closure there's a vibration this is yes
so this is a back wrap now this back
wrap on here your remote you can control
heat vibration and my favorite part the
lumbar support it's a really nice guys
so do you feel that lumbar support I
feel the I feel it all of our support
it's like inflate yes so you can choose
how you want that whether you want a
good inflation a little bit less same
thing with heat same with the vibration
so whether you're chasing a toddler or
you're starting that exercise routine
you sit in a chair all day a lot of us
have lower back issues including me this
is like a dream come true look we just
bought gifts for everyone in the world
yeah time to buy a little something
first okay all right January new year
new year with all of us working from
home so much more this would be nice to
have while you're working working on
scripts and stories working
I might need to keep this on the rest of
the morning all right then nine foot
cord by the way and it also has a USB so
you can plug it right into you know a
charger and walk around with it
hands-free too how much is that so this
one is right now 32 savings which is
amazing it's 47.99 okay and your back's
gonna feel so much better I like that
buying gifts for everybody buy this for
yourself mom mom needs a gift too you
know don't cheat yourself treat yourself
exactly I like that go ahead and use it
all right I just want to thank you so
much of course we partner with all of
these companies to get the best deals to
buy anything that you saw scan the QR
code on your screen right now or head
over to cbsdeals.com to start shopping
now for these products and many many
more we will be right back